jean claude et qu'en ville bonjour oui
bonjour monsieur caruge bonjour à tous
les éditeurs
merci de répondre à nos questions vous
êtes maire du carbet vous avez déjà deux
mandats à votre actif
vous êtes candidat donc pour tenter un
troisième mandat mais alors pourquoi
être candidat surtout que certains
disent au carbet que vous auriez avancé
que vous ne seriez engagé que pour deux
mandats
l'état fait tout à fait je j'assume
j'assume effectivement j'avais dit que
je m'engageais sur deux modèles mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui fort de ce que nous
avons réalisé un joli nom pour ce que tu
une équipe
les élus et moi même fort de ce que nous
avons réalisé et puis particulièrement
projection de ce que nous voulons faire
voilà donc je veux véritablement que le
carbet continue à se développer
d'ailleurs c'est une continuité et j'ai
souhaité avec toute l'équipe bien
entendu continuer continuer cette
mission cette fonction me fais travail
pour pouvoir réussir et glorifié aux
regards donc c'est l'équipe l'équipe qui
vous a demandé de vous représenter à
nouveau ou ses voûtes seul qui avait
pris cette décision et vous leur avait
proposé d'être à nouveau candidat
l'équipe m'a demandé mais en fait moi
aussi j'ai tout à fait de nos semblait
nous ne fonctionnons j'ai toujours dit
que mr n'est que l'animateur mais être
l'animateur est un animateur d'une
équipe avec un jeu je suis très fier de
cette équipe est que n'y avait pas ce
que parce que certains disent au carbet
que la relève était déjà peut-être prête
depuis plusieurs années même nom la
relève ne dépendant pas prête et c'est
bien pourquoi je continue et
effectivement nous allons préparer la
relève pour que le futur soit bien
assurée alors jean claude decamps ville
si vous êtes réélu pour un troisième
mandat
quel serait votre dossier numéro un
une fois revenu aux affaires de la
municipalité car des siennes deuxième
numéro un
l'économie touristique c'est clair je
crois que nous avons réussi d'hiver en
différentes sculptures le social
tourisme économie je crois que quand on
veut assure une commune que devait
assurer le bien-être d'une commune il
faut véritablement réussir l'économique
alors le social je vous passe les 10
lily est vrai nous avons fait une
centaine de logements
s'il voudrait aussi que avec vous aider
même si nous avons perdu des subsides
est liée à la 7ème et nous avons
effectivement travaillé sur le social la
culture le sport
nous avons des associations
véritablement nous avons un tissu mais
très fort et aujourd'hui il faut émettre
mais qu'est ce qui reste à faire
notamment est-ce que vous avez une
difficulté particulière au sein de la
municipalité
je pas moins d'ordre budgétaire ou de
moyens techniques je fais tout ce que je
veux dire quelqu'un comme toutes les
mairies même si nous avons retrouvé un
équilibre budgétaire même si notre
budget est excédentaire mais nous avons
toutes les difficultés et bien sûr nous
sommes orientés vers au fort partenariat
très très fort avec des trophées se
priver et donc aujourd'hui cela
fonctionne savez aujourd'hui ça vous
savez le carbet rayonne de tous feux
dits restaurant sur la plage des
entreprises qui fonctionnent bien des
gens des promoteurs qui veut c'est sale
et au carbet bien sûr bien sûr on va pas
oublier le fameux marouba qui ne dépend
pas de nous à quoi l'homme
alors voilà encore quelques mots
là-dessus c'est vrai que bon à l'aune de
ce que vous dites
un certain nombre de choses ont été
faites concernant le littoral alors bon
plus ou moins bien apprécié par vos
administrés ils en décideront en mars
prochain
mais l'arrière pays la ruralité carbis
yen est ce que vous vous en préoccuper
aussi jean claude descamps est tout à
fait tout à fait d'ailleurs c'est aussi
une des raisons qui me poussent à
continuer effectivement les pythons
parlant des pythons qui sont dit
d'autant plus tendue car au bo du mont
le vernois tu as fait c'est une blague
que j'ai fait à mon ami a eu c'est ça
libère le maire de bordeaux vers le vert
qui voudraient lui que ça s'appelle les
lecteurs voilà c'est dit joue l'épisode
associer les noms des deux comme mères
nous sommes tellement en brutalisation
que pourquoi pas pourquoi on est content
quand on dit que la rivière du carbet
est une des rivières nos pour lui
c'était contre quand on dit
qu'aujourd'hui que les touristes se
précipitent vers les pythons et bien
nous disons que aux à la rivière il faut
associer l'agriculture est donc
aujourd'hui aussi nous avons ce projet
de rouadi mentionné la lépi taux de
redimensionner la route des pythons de
redonner de la vie
et de la structure au piton
effectivement vous avez raison c'est la
ruralité qui est aussi un des axes de la
prochaine mandature
alors on va terminer puisque vous avez
un peu tout ramasser on se souvient il
n'ya pas longtemps puisque vous avez
fait allusion à des aides que vous
n'auriez pas eu de la ctm et on sait
qu'il ya un conseiller territorial
exécutif qui sera votre concurrent votre
rival pour la prochaine élection
louis boutrin il faut le nommer il y
avait une polémique a pas longtemps à
propos de l'ouverture de la piscine là
encore entre mairie et et collectivités
territoriales bon est-ce que vous avez
sortir ça risque de s'exacerber là dans
les semaines et mois qui viennent
rivalité avec lui boutrin ben ça c'est
vous en faites vous en faites votre
principal adversaire
nous non pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout chez des adversaires qui sont là et
puis on verra
la population a décidé non il n'y a pas
de polémique à avoir su cette piscine la
piscine et territoriale est dépend de la
collectivité
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs pourquoi on a
voulu me les la mairie à cette affaire
donc
écoutez donc là c'est bon c'est réglé sa
piscine c'est d'ailleurs pour que les
audits disent qu'ils puissent entendre
c'est du domaine de la collectivité
territoriales de la martinique est
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de n'avons
rien à y voir
sinon effectivement assurer une sécurité
aux abords de l'enclos des camps ville
merci bonne journée